do you think the worst person you came
into contact with there's a guy he's
committed over 120 offenses on school
girls he was CCTV aware but there was a
couple of girls that had been attacked
and then changed their route to school
and he got him again we've tried
absolutely everything we can think of
but we just can't get this guy we're
gonna put a decoy out you in the school
uniform so for two weeks I stood at this
particular bus stop and then I heard at
this like tap in as I went to turn he's
got me around the throw and he's just
pulled me to the floor and ejaculated
all over me so I had a camera on my back
and when he was creeping he was
masturbating with me so he got him to
the point of you needed to be out and
then he just all over me but there was a
safety team on that so that if he did
get me they would come and get him so we
had someone in that house we had been
men he was on The Truman Show he didn't
realize him I got a letter from one of
the girls mums now the little girl knew
that he'd been put in prison she could
now sleep at night she was no longer
taking sleeping tablets and she didn't
wet the bed anymore and I felt like
that's what I joined for
the true Geordie podcast